we're taking you way back in time this
morning nearly 200 million years to the
Jurassic era in a new book the rise and
fall of the dinosaurs paleontologist
Steve Bruce Otte explores the lives of
those great extinct animals he invited
us to see what's left of them
only on CBS this morning Jonathan
Vigliotti visits a real dinosaur
graveyard off the coast of northern
Scotland hundreds of millions of years
have weathered Scotland's remote Isle of
Skye and the prehistoric secrets that
are buried in its wrinkles have
attracted a caravan of Time Traveler's
this is spectacular
American paleontologist Steve Bruce Adi
invited us on his research teams quest
we're detectives now for the next hour
okay I'm just gonna warn everybody be
careful you never really know what
you're gonna find Sam Bruce Adi has
traveled to some of the world's most
extreme landscapes you know I loved
dinosaurs before I study dinosaurs is
the Olive Sky is Scotland a new frontier
for this research I think Scotland is
one of the most exciting new frontiers
for dinosaurs and there's still a lot of
fossils to find here and they're
important fossils important because they
come from the middle part of the
Jurassic period of which little is known
a time when dinosaurs evolved from the
size of house cats
into the monsters brought to life by
Hollywood in this real-life Jurassic
Park
Bruce Adi is in pursuit of what could be
steady sore bones it's over here Doogie
the discovery trapped in a boulder look
okay you can see the texture there it
has the grain of bone and it has that
porous honeycomb type of texture believe
it or not these orange markings are
prehistoric bones preserved in sandstone
this is a set of bones that Steve and
his team have been looking for for well
over a year they have found them but now
the next challenge is trying to extract
this rock to get those bones into a lab
for studying so if those are two
different bones you'd have to lady bones
paleontology is a lot like detective
work detectives put people behind bars
what's your end game here we put fossils
in museums so people can see them people
can enjoy them people can get inspired
by them in the past 15 years
Bruce Adi has helped identify 15 new
species of dinosaur a dinosaur Hondas
that's what it's called in the
profession well it sounds good doesn't
it he took us a few miles down the coast
I always say it I know it's a little bit
lame but this is a real Jurassic Park to
a real Jurassic Laguna's they're covered
by water so much of the time but when
the tide goes out a Land Before Time is
revealed about 170 million years ago
this would have been a watering hole and
today you can literally walk in the
footsteps of these dinosaurs these
prints here believed to belong to the
brontosaurus Bruce Oddie's team
discovered around 50 dinosaur prints in
this one location and you can kind of
see okay it's about the size of a
basketball maybe a little bit bigger and
then it has something there something
there something there and those are toes
so this is a dinosaur footprint I would
never have guessed
so 170 million years ago you had this
dinosaur this Jeep size plant eating
dinosaur literally stepping right here
Bruce Adi believes everything from long
neck sauropods to pterodactyls roamed
this part of earth until an asteroid
likely wiped them out
some people say lumbering and foolish
but you make a point of saying don't
call them stupid some of them were
enormous others evolved into birds some
of them were very smart so for me
they're nature's ultimate success story
and what do you think the lesson is for
humans in all of this I think the lesson
for us is that the earth is really old
the earth changes a lot climates change
environments change and sometimes the
species that are the best adapted for a
certain climate or environment if
something changes they can go extinct
and that happened to the dinosaurs and
if it could happen to the dinosaurs that
were around for a hundred and fifty some
million years could that also happen us
a journey to the past may help us see
into the future for CBS this morning
Jonathan Vigliotti on the Isle of Skye
well I'm glad we saw a dinosaur
footprint because halfway through it
Nora and I both go where is a dinosaur
bone where's the dinosaur head that's
very very fascinating that all these
years later it's still there and if you
want to see real dinosaurs a movie opens
this Friday okay Jurassic Park there
you're gonna see the real dinosaur bit
too now it's Friday